let's say you're visiting earth for the
first time
and the tour of the planet consists of
being dropped into random locations for
about five seconds before being whisked
away to an entirely different spot on
the globe if you knew nothing whatsoever
about life on earth how might you
interpret what you saw at first these
narrow glimpses of a vast world would be
confusing and probably a little bizarre
but over time as the brief snapshots
formed a greater whole you might be able
to get a sense of broader patterns of
life here on earth
exobiotica is a speculative biology
project by incredible artist michael
beaudry that offers similarly limited
windows into the sprawling alien
biosphere of a planet called vateris in
the words of the artist each composition
is a tip of an iceberg a momentary and
fleeting glimpse into an entire
ecosystem
and the life forms we can document are
uniquely alien even by the standards of
speculative biology yet the more art you
observe the more you begin to understand
the larger stories of life upon planet
veteries so for this entry into the
archive we'll shine a light on the
secrets of each region and uncover how
the larger ecosystems fit together and
as always you can follow and support the
artist using the links in the
description now let's head off towards
planet veteries and prepare for our
first glimpse of this world of mysteries
planet victories lies beyond the
outskirts of a stunning nebula
the very name veteries gives us some
understanding of the nature of this
world as it means ancient in latin and
indeed this planet is quite old relative
to earth at almost 8 billion years since
this is nearly twice the age of our home
planet there's no telling what life has
emerged time for a closer look
touching down on vateries our first
glimpse of the teeming surface is
difficult to comprehend at a glance it's
hard to tell which of these organisms
are plants and which are animals on
earth broad categories like plants
animals and fungi are useful in the
classification of life forms and it's
rare that one would mistake one for the
other but the life forms on vateries
resist such classifications entirely and
many remain unnamed the large plotting
walkers in this image move like animals
yet they can photosynthesize
the flower-like life-forms might look
like plants but they can walk on their
spindly legs the long rope-like
organisms that carpet the ground can't
walk but do grow at a rapid pace to mark
their territory even the rock-like
spheres are secretly alert employing an
electrochemical defense to keep the
creeping tendrils at bay the end result
is an ecosystem with extreme
biodiversity that is truly difficult for
us earthlings to comprehend but the more
locations we visit the more we'll
understand
the twisting matrix of tendrils define a
region known as the low forest and here
we'll discover another unusual organism
roaming amidst the strands this is
adachia a generalist hunter that walks
upon three flexible hydraulic legs which
are powered by pressurized liquid an
organism powering their legs with
hydraulics might sound like pure sci-fi
yet surprisingly many types of arachnids
actually use pressurized liquid to help
power their spindly legs and since
veteries gravity is lesser than earth's
we'll find many organisms get around on
similar hydraulic tubes aside from its
locomotive limbs the dacia possesses
small grasping appendages to help it
apprehend prey and communicate with
other members of its species for the
dacia is a fairly clever and naturally
curious life form which can sometimes
lead it into trouble
for the most part dacha's stick to the
low forest when searching for food in
our next snapshot however we can see
adachia standing at the threshold of a
very different kind of environment an
organic cave marks the entrance to the
otherwise sealed glow forest encouraged
by the prospect of shelter the dacia
considers entering the dark yet inviting
refuge but what will it find inside
entering another snapshot we can see
that within the glow forest a mysterious
ecosystem awaits since this region
possesses such a thick canopy virtually
no light reaches the life forms that
dwell within as a result these organisms
have evolved a startling array of
bioluminescent displays on earth surreal
pageants of bioluminescence can be found
throughout the depths of the oceans
these remarkable spectacles of light are
thought to serve a variety of functions
from communicating to attracting prey to
warding off predators
and in the glow forest the mysterious
displays are equally diverse this
particular organism possesses glowing
bands on its back likely to attract a
mate the vibrant colors and slug-like
locomotive appendages of this life-form
call to mind certain genera of marine
gastropods and with a sharp stinger-like
protrusion on its front end this doesn't
seem like a particularly friendly
customer
closer to the forest floor vertical
glowing bulbs sprout from the ground in
vast quantities the vibrant light
they're emitting indicates these bulbs
are on the cusp of reproducing but they
might never get the chance for they are
under siege by a slow-moving yet
ever-hungry behemoth a laterna pulmonous
although a placid and rather
unintelligent sort of fellow this
organism is nonetheless a serious threat
to the glowing bulbs like its food
source the latino pulmonis possesses
purple bioluminescence which helps it
blend into the surrounding forest so
unless a very sharp-eyed predator comes
along the laternapalminus will likely
continue snacking
in the murky ponds on the floor of the
glow forest we can glimpse a
surprisingly diverse community of
organisms that thrive in these cloudy
pools a miniature forest of towering
colonial microorganisms dominates the
landscape feeding off methane gas
released by decaying organic matter upon
this bedrock of the food chain a
plethora of creatures creep and crawl
about their daily lives on our planet
similar dramas unfold in coastal rock
pools and while these pools might seem
peaceful they are actually battlegrounds
for survival predators like the starfish
are constantly on the prowl and in turn
they are sometimes swallowed up by
certain sea anemones which grow large
enough to consume almost anything in the
pool and on veteries a similarly
ravenous goliath terrorizes the murky
ponds in the distance the pond's top
predator rises above the towers a
mysterious and shadowy leviathan that
devours everything in its path other
creatures need to keep their distance
far from the dimness of the glow forest
our next snapshot brings us to the vast
plains here we can see a group of
spindly lifeforms called the
magnavindics engaging in a very
intriguing behavior these imposing
creatures which stand around 15 feet or
4 meters in height are shepherds of
sorts keeping watch over their unusual
flock they spend their days hurting the
placid defenseless lumentis that are
their main source of food on earth
several species of ants are known to
engage in a similar behavior these ants
are hurting aphids small rotund insects
that excrete a sugary liquid that the
ants feed on in exchange the ants go to
great lengths to care for their wards
protecting them from predators carrying
them to new pasture lands to feed and
even encouraging them to reproduce and
the magnavindex are similarly involved
in the lives of the lumentus playing the
role of both defender and matchmaker
bringing pairs of lumentus together when
their biolite signal they're ready to
mate indeed this symbiosis has grown to
the point where the lumentus have no
conception of danger and are free to
grow heavy and slow as they graze upon
the expanse of fibrous purple organisms
that dominate this land
looking through another window on
vetteris it seems symbiosis has emerged
in other unexpected formulations this
spherical life form is a round walker
and while it might not look particularly
mobile it does in fact amble slowly on
its long spindly legs at the moment this
particular round walker is beleaguered
by a flock of flat parasites clinging to
its surface if the round walker isn't
bothered for its surface is tended to by
a spiny little fellow called a guardian
like their name suggests guardians are
the defenders of the round walkers as
well as their cleaning service in an
exchange the round walkers serve as
their living mobile homes this
mutualistic symbiosis has converged on a
partnership similar to that of sea and
enemies and clownfish certain anemones
rely on clownfish heavily as clownfish
both keep the anemones clean provide
nutrients in the form of waste and scare
off any would-be pillagers in return the
anemone's tentacles provide a safe home
for the tiny clownfish
the guardians and round walkers are
similarly linked to the point where
you'll never find either species on
their own and so the round walkers amble
along each crowned by a spiny guardian
defending their small world
but not all organisms are so harmonious
deep within a forested valley a familiar
arms race has emerged in some very
unfamiliar life forms here a predatory
creature called the veloxos follows its
hunting path by the river it's a capable
hunter with three powerful hydraulic
legs and a harpoon-like proboscis which
extends almost the full length of its
body and this veloxis has spotted its
prey a dish-faced centipede that has
emerged from the undergrowth for a drink
the centipede's appearance helps it
blend in among inactive life forms on
the forest floor much like how earth's
bargabont seahorses have evolved to
almost perfectly resemble the sessile
stalks of coral but like the specialized
horse the septiped's camouflage only
works for specific environments and in
this light it's dangerously exposed
moments from now an intense chase will
begin between predator and prey no
matter which species triumphs the
perpetual theater of natural selection
will continue across the planet
natural selection doesn't just breed
competition on land however our next
glimpse shows us a scene below the waves
of this alien world here the quick and
nimble sea swifts jet along the currents
sporting long lateral spikes to keep
predators at bay
spikes are a common defense in the
natural world with certain types of
marine gastropods having converged on
similar lateral defenses near the spiky
sea swifts the more vulnerable bubble
swimmers drift along these filter
feeders use wave like ripples in their
translucent outer membrane to propel
themselves slowly through the current
both the sea swifts and the bubble
swimmers are on their own in these vast
oceans but other species have partnered
up the glass coligadio is a composite
organism a creature composed of multiple
species that share critical biological
processes between them in the glass
coligadio's case the larger swimmer
provides mobility while its multi-legged
symbiote feeds more effectively than it
could alone as discussed before on this
channel numerous organisms on earth are
also comprised of multiple life forms
working in tandem to survive yet
curiously interdependence between two
separate species appears far more common
on victories than on earth a trend that
will only strengthen the more life forms
we observe
near the surface of this world's oceans
one can on rare occasions catch a
glimpse of a bizarre display an
entourage of deep sea behemoths are
making a brief ascent to the surface
releasing gelatinous strings of embryos
here in the sunlight where their young
will have better visibility upon
hatching while a life-form blindly
releasing huge clouds of their children
into the wild might sound like a bad
strategy it mirrors that of many life
forms on earth in general there are two
main reproductive strategies on our
planet organisms that are k strategists
produce fewer young but place a greater
investment into each ensuring a higher
percentage of their children reach
adulthood but there also are strategists
which flood the ecosystem with progeny
so that regardless of how many don't
make it at least some are likely to
survive long enough to reproduce
while the behemoths are clearly our
strategists their children won't be
completely on their own a swarm of
intrigued lifeforms tail behind the
behemoths and will become unwitting
hosts for their multitudeness offspring
the embryos will stick to and develop
upon the surface of these surrogate
species until they're ready to hatch and
repeat the cycle luckily for the host
species however they won't suffer any
ill effects from their temporary
parasites
in the murky blackness of the deep sea
many creatures use bioluminescence
similar to the life forms of the glow
forest the amusingly named gullible
vagari wander the depths looking for the
matching biolite of another member of
its species described as a hopeless
romantic whether the vagarie search ends
in success or tragedy is a matter of
fate for there is a dangerous predator
skulking in the abyss
the giant illicio is an organism that
has evolved bioluminescent appendages
that mimic the light of the vagari its
main food source and lure them into its
jaws
this low energy hunting method has
resulted in a cumbersome lifeform that
isn't particularly hydrodynamic on earth
the lumpy frog fish have a similarly
ungainly body plan due to a convergent
lifestyle like the giant illicio the
frogfish baits its prey with a
specialized lure on the front of its
head after all when your food comes to
you you don't have to be particularly
mobile
back on land a life form known as the
sun worshiper leads a placid and
cautious existence high above the ground
like many other mobile creatures on
veteries the sun worshiper receives a
portion of its energy from
photosynthesis as evidenced by the
specially adapted appendages radiating
from its body to stay safe the sun
worshiper has evolved eye spots on its
appendages which give predators the
impression of a much more formidable
opponent this sort of defensive mimicry
is convergent with that of various earth
prey animals perhaps most notably the
eye spots on the wings of certain types
of butterflies for a creature that wants
to stay hidden the coloration of the sun
worshiper might seem strange or even
gaudy by our terrestrial standards but
in its native habitat the bright red
serves as excellent camouflage and in a
world as extreme as victories it pays to
blend in
our second to last glimpse at planet
veteries is one of the most striking
here the ruler of a misty valley watches
as a competitor makes their approach
these lifeforms are greater confo highly
territorial organisms that do battle
with a set of forward-facing hydraulic
spears this disputed territory is a
surreal landscape of fluid-filled
branching growths called kamsenas a type
of photosynthetic life-form analogous to
trees and this biome has hidden dangers
the glowing orange gel that coats the
forest floor is tasty and extremely
sticky designed to ensnare hungry life
forms that will later be consumed
overhead a flock of bicolor mikens have
noticed this accumulation and are flying
in mass to take advantage of it but
doing so carefully for even a creature
as large as the invading confo might
become trapped if it's not vigilant
and in our last image we can see a scene
where seasonal rains have blessed an
arid region here desert runners life
forms with now familiar tripodal body
plans congregate for a drink but the
allure of water has drawn in another
organism as well the unparalleled
monolith these living towers send thick
tendrils towards the shallow pools to
drink their fill the monolith may only
get the chance to drink in this way two
or three times a year but it's enough to
keep the structure alive during drier
periods and along the surface of the
monolith glowing biolite shimmer in the
setting sun these points of light are
signals to the nox that soar nearby
flyers that roost within the monolith
during the day and in return provide the
structure with discarded food each nox
can actually recognize the unique
pattern of biolites on their home
monolith out of the crowd of others this
final example of symbiosis may have been
a surprise at the beginning of our
journey but now it's just another
familiar expression of planet veterice's
broader patterns
like an alien witnessing earth's
splendor in brief snapshots our
understanding of planet victories will
always be somewhat limited but now we've
observed enough moments across the
planet's surface to understand many of
its fascinating systems it's been a
unique viewing experience and there may
be more to come
according to the creator the larger
exobiotica project will eventually cover
other planets beyond the world of
veteries that will harbor entirely new
forms of life but for now if you enjoyed
discovering the secrets of michael
beaudry's incredible compositions you
can once again follow and support the
artist to see more exciting
illustrations using the links in the
description
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you